more than 400,000 customers across the
mid-atlantic and northeast are without
power after severe storms slammed the
region's overnight and we're just
getting word that a tornado likely hit
Pennsylvania in Delaware County
Pennsylvania officials are assessing the
damage this morning the storms tore down
trees and power lines causing severe
flooding in some areas chip Reid is in
Washington chip good morning so how bad
is the damage where you are well it's
not too bad we were under a tornado
watch for much of the night fortunately
there were no tornadoes here but the
winds were howling and brought down lots
of trees like this one that they're
working on now and of course brought
down the power lines with them
torrential rains and winds up to 60
miles an hour took down trees and power
lines in several states leaving tens of
thousands without power north of here in
Ellicott City Maryland an area prone to
flooding creeks over ran their banks
closing roads the storm also slammed
parts of Pennsylvania and New Jersey and
brought down dozens of trees from New
York City to Long Island very sadly in
New Rochelle New York a young girl was
hit by a tree as it fell while she was
trick-or-treating we do not know her
condition at this time the good news is
no severe weather in this part of the
country for today Gail
oh boy sorry to hear about that
trick-or-treater thank you very much
chip